et avec nous sur ce plateau cédric
nouvelot secrétaire départemental des
républicains dans le calvados
avant de parler du mode d'emploi de la
primaire de la droite et du centre
un mot sur la candidature d'emmanuel
macron moi je laisse à la gauche ses
divisions objets qu'ils ont du mal à
s'entendre même sur l'organisation
dehors de leurs primaires juste rappeler
que emmanuel macron comme coty voltaire
seront de toute façon comptable du bilan
mauvais de françois hollande il faut pas
oublier qu'il a quand même été ministre
d'économie quand on voit la situation
économique du pays
il ya quand même quelques questions à se
poser alors je le disais dans trois
jours les français sont appelés à voter
pour le premier tour de la primaire de
la droite et du centre chacun devra
verser deux euros au titre de
l'organisation pour financer la location
des salles notamment il y à 448 bureaux
de vote répartis sur l'ensemble de la
normandie et puis chaque électeur devra
également signé une charte
la voici je partage des valeurs
républicaines de la droite et du centre
et je m'engage pour l'alternance afin de
réussir le redressement de la france
beaucoup de personnes se demandent où
aller voter
qu'est ce qu'on leur dit justement
qu'est-ce qu'il faut savoir y est un
site internet qui permet de se
renseigner à vous montrer le code postal
où vous rentrez le nom de votre commune
ça vous donne l'endroit le bureau vous
avez même le plan d'accès pour vous
rendre à ce bureau de vote
on vote dans les communes qui est dans
la commune qui sont rattachés au bureau
de vote principal donc vous retrouver
ces informations sur le site internet
vous pouvez aussi appeler de plus il
intéresse je vais le donner à ces ww
point primaire 2016 point org s'affiche
à l'écran
voilà le numéro de téléphone c'est le 0
800 21-20 2016 0 821 20 2016 vous pouvez
avoir tous ces enseignements eelv on
trouve aussi sur
les sites internet également la presse
écrite les renseignements alors il n'y a
pas un bureau de vote dans toutes les
communes fois bien le savoir c'est pas
en allant à sa mairie comme pour une
élection municipale aux régionales que
l'on va pouvoir voter non lors sur les
mairies seront peut-être fermer
d'ailleurs sur le calvados ya 105
bureaux de vote ça représente déjà quand
même 800 bénévoles pour les tenir je
tiens d'ailleurs à les remercier parce
que c'est un gros travail
ça fait un gros travail d'organisation
de la commission qui est présidée par
sophie gaugain on a de vrais au sein de
cette commission pour organiser donc
effectivement sont cinq bureaux de vote
je rappelle que ce sera ouvert de 8
heures à 19 heures comme vous l'avez
rappelé il faut 2 euros en espèces qu'il
faut être muni de sa pièce d'identité
pas de la carte d'électeur c'est la
pièce d'identité
il faut être inscrit sur les listes
électorales donc de la côte du bureau de
rattachement
et puis il faudrait effectivement signé
la charte alors tout le monde peut voter
on l'a rappelé on gardera dans les
archives les noms des participants des
électeurs dont ceux qui ont signé cette
charte qui pourraient être des militants
de gauche ou du front national n'ont
lancé une primaire ouverte à tous elle a
été faite avec des règles qui permettent
d'être ni contester ni contestable et
vous aurez les cahiers qui seront signés
pour la charte est également les listes
d'émargement qui seront l'issue du
scrutin détruit sous contrôle d'huissier
on n'aura absolument pas accès aux
données aux informations personnelles
merci cédric nouvelot d'avoir précisé ce
mode d'emploi de la primaire premier
tour donc dimanche à noter que les
bureaux de vote seront ouverts de 8
heures à 19 heures avant la procuration
je dis merci